en termes de formation et d'égalité au
travail les stéréotypes ont la vie dure
depuis 25 ans l'association fait agi
pour lutter contre ces discriminations
dans les étapes du parcours
professionnel et je reçois carla
martinez chargé de communication de
cette association
[Musique]
bonjour bonjour merci d'être avec nous
merci de m'avoir invité
alors je le disais un quart de siècle
d'existence pour fait qui signifie femme
et techniques femmes égalité emploi
on avait gagné des emplois voilà
pourquoi est ce que cette association
s'est créée il ya 25 ans alors non
fondatrice il ya 25 ans se sont rendus
compte que les jeunes filles au collège
par exemple choisissez souvent des
métiers qui étaient déjà très féminisés
donc des métiers dans les domaines par
exemple de la santé de l'enseignement
tout ce qui est administratif et elle
voyait qu'il y avait beaucoup de filles
qui avaient versé filière là et qu
ensuite plus tard dans la vie
professionnelle
elle savait plus de difficultés que les
garçons à s'insérer dans la vie
professionnelle
également les salaires étaient plus bas
elle savait dès souvent des contrats
précaires
ce qu'on voit encore aujourd'hui et donc
c'est pour ça qu'elles sont sûrs cette
idée là et d'essayer d'aider les jeunes
filles des femmes à diversifier leurs
choix d'orientation
alors comment est-ce que ça évolue tous
à quel constat vous faites aujourd'hui
25 ans après alors depuis 25 ans c'est
vrai que l'on voit de plus en plus des
femmes dans certains métiers
ça avance doucement il est vrai que
malgré les stéréotypes qui persiste
encore aujourd'hui parce qu'ils sont la
vie dure de plus en plus de jeunes
filles osent aller vers des métiers où
il ya une majorité ya eu une prise de
conscience il y à une prise de
conscience
effectivement de la part des filles des
femmes mais également de leur entourage
des enseignants des employeurs aussi
parce qu'elle deux employeurs avaient
souvent de réticences à embaucher des
femmes dans ces métiers là alors les
mentalités évoluent lentement mais elle
évolue comme un exemple avec le portrait
de cette femme promoteurs dans la
rénovation de patrimoine de prestige
elle a dû jouer des coudes pour se faire
une place dans un milieu très masculin
regarde le reportage de valérie très tôt
et marc millet jeannette guinaudeau est
à l'affût du patrimoine de la rochelle
des perles rares comme cet hôtel
particulier du xviiie siècle
on va reprendre toutes les rosaces à
l'identique toutes les boiseries et
c'est absolument exceptionnel d'avoir
ça à la rochelle des plafonds art déco
créée au 20e siècle par un banquier qui
s'installe dans l'immeuble jeannette a
prévu 18 mois de chantier pour réaliser
huit logements
l'hôtel est inscrit aux monuments
historiques et elle va tenter de sauver
les vestiges du passé
voyez ça c'est exceptionnel c'est
restitue l identique jeannette
guinaudeau est l'une des rares femmes
promoteurs dans la restauration des
meubles anciens
très vite elle laisse tomber son métier
de coiffeuse pour se lancer dans
l'immobilier
en 2000 elle fonde sa société le groupe
est en plein essor avec une dizaine
d'emplois créés et une success-story
féminine clairement revendiquée je suis
vraiment une autodidacte effectivement
et être une femme dans ce métier départ
c'est très difficile puisque c'est un
métier quand même masculin mais par
contre aujourd'hui 16 ans après je peux
dire que je suis très respecté dans ce
métier et je n'ai plus du tout cette
sensation qu'être une femme soit un
problème mais il a vraiment fallu faire
ses preuves pour en arriver là
et voici l'une de ses réalisations une
bâtisse du xviiie aménagé en 28
logements dont ce triplex 227 mètres
carrés l'objectif c'était de restituer
tous les beaux éléments notamment ici
les vitraux nous avons aussi un très bel
escalier anciens et là la particularité
ces caisses qu'allié dessert en fait
l'intégralité du logement jeanne est
investi un peu partout dans le sud ouest
mais sa présence est la rochelle ne
passe pas inaperçu elle continue de
dénicher des bâtisses du passé pour les
mettre au goût du jour
alors voilà pour cet exemple quels sont
les secteurs où ça évolue favorablement
ou les mentalités évoluent le plus
ingénieux transport sécurité notamment
oui oui dans celle les ingénieurs il y a
plus de femmes qu'il ya quelques années
dans le secteur d'ingénieurs par exemple
on peut voir ça même si elle reste
encore il y a environ 27% des femmes
dans le secteur d'ingénieurs donc c'est
pas non plus énorme dans tout ce qui est
transport effectivement on voit plus de
femmes conductrices par exemple de bus
souvent il ya même deux constructeurs
lourd même si on les voit un peu moins
souvent dans la sécurité également
tout ce qui est police armée elle reste
très minoritaire mais ça avance
effectivement
al'inverse les nouvelles technologies
notamment le domaine de l'informatique
n'attire pas vraiment les jeunes filles
comment est-ce que vous l'expliquer
alors c'est un secteur en plein boom 1
qui se développent et beaucoup d'intérêt
que c'est un maître un secteur porteur
où il y a vraiment des embauches et on
n'arrive pas trop à expliquer pourquoi
les jeunes filles ne sont pas très
attiré par ces métiers là moi je pense
que c'est dû à l'image comme pour
beaucoup de métier c'est ce sont des
préjugés des images qu'on a dans la tête
et les jeunes filles n'aiment pas
forcément cette image de rester collé à
son ordinateur
le geek entre guillemets comment comme
on dit et ça oui elle trouve pas ça
vraiment attractif alors je le disais
lors l'association fêtes organise depuis
20 ans on carrefour des carrières au
féminin pourquoi est-ce que vingt ans
après on a encore besoin d'organiser un
événement comme celui-ci
oui ben pour l'instant même après 20 ans
de cet événement les filles et les
garçons allaient métier on va dire on va
dire son nom mixte il y a très peu de
métiers qui sont vraiment mixte donc
pour nom c'est encore nécessaire de
répéter chaque année le même message
dire aux jeunes filles
vous êtes capable d'exercer tous les
métiers comme les garçons n'hésitez pas
à aller voir des métiers que vous
connaissez pas de métier peut-être qui
vous semblent inaccessibles et c'est
pour ça que par cet événement là par
l'exemple nous on montre génie le
principe c'est justement c'est comme un
forum des changes en fait on rencontre
des professionnels
oui exactement des femmes que des femmes
un écran les femmes uniquement des
femmes qui exercent des métiers où elles
sont peu nombreuses et elles viennent
vraiment parfois même avec des habits de
travail en uniforme avec des outils pour
parler leur parcours pour expliquer un
peu leurs difficultés d'insertion dans l
visiteuse peuvent poser toutes les
questions qu'elles veulent sur la
formation le parcours le choix du métier
et le quotidien du métier comment ça se
passe avec leurs collègues hommes par
exemple donc effectivement c'est un
échange libre pour découvrir ces métiers
là voilà ça commence samedi à dijon en
côte d'or il y en a jusqu'au 10 février
à autun nombre dans les quatre
départements bourguignons je crois bien
tout un carrière un carrefour des
carrières en franche comté c'est prévu
peut-être pour l'année franchis l'année
prochaine doit l'être
merci beaucoup carla martinez c'est là